That was
close.
I forget about this piece every time.
Okay, so now I just need to get into this thing.
Ultrasonic scan.
Go here.
40,000 points.
Sweet.
40,000.
Okay, so as far as I understand, that's good.
Alright, now I'm going to put on this guy finally.
Alright, and I need one of those connection thingies.
That's not the right size.
I just happened to grab a big one.
It'll be a lot easier.
Okay.
This needs to be set to 50.
15.
17.
50.
All right.
Test.
That looks good.
40,200.
Perfect.
Got that.
20 watts of power.
Good.
So put this in here.
So no.
That is too.
Oh crap.
You know what?
I said we're going to do these with.
Carbon fiber because those are the cheapest.
So that's great.
I gotta redo this That's amazing
how hot that gets Okay, so there's a
little bit of aluminum on it still Well, I
can see if this atomizes still I think it will.
I don't see any issues with it, but we will know Unfortunately
science research is very not efficient 50
So they're like straight lines.
Wow.
Hot again.
Graphite's supposed to be brittle.
How brittle?
I'm not really sure.
Haven't had that experience yet.
I think these are graphite.
Maybe probably something else.
Some metal.
I'm glad it's metal.
These will get worn out real quick if they're plastic.
That's tight.
Where's this guy sitting?
Hopefully that's a good spot for it.
All right.
So I think we're set now.
I just need to prepare our material for it.